mergers and acquisitions are one of the
most important means by which companies
respond to changing economic and
financial conditions it has become one
of the favourite exit strategies for
many entrepreneurs and startups
especially here in Silicon Valley
the unfortunate reality however is that
the majority of M&A transactions fail to
provide the benefits that companies
predict or expect to gain this time for
GSP mergers and acquisition program is
an interdisciplinary overview of all the
major aspects of M&A transactions I
wanted to attend a program to better
understand how different companies and
different industries go through the
acquisition process from strategy to
integration that gives you exposure to a
lot of deals and a lot of thinking I've
had different levels of M&A experience
what this program was able to do for me
was have that entire lifecycle talk
about it with people who have had
different experiences and help my
company develop our core strategy one of
the keys to a success of an M&A
transaction is understanding the
perspective in the mindset of the person
on the other side the negotiation class
helps solidify the concepts in a very
practical manner and doing case studies
outside of what you're comfortable with
is very very powerful
so the program offers participants an
opportunity to get immersed in an
intense yet very collaborative learning
environments our goal is really to
provide program participants with
critical insights and powerful tools
that will help them more successfully
formulate and execute emerges an
acquisition strategy they can really
create value for their organizations
people like me who've done a lot of
acquisitions already that the benefit is
just kind of sharpening your skills
thinking differently the program is
something that I'm taking back into my
organization day one